[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit diesem schiff soll in basel ein
neuer kulturort entstehen
das wiederum sei aber als einmaliges
ereignis will so viel herzblut der
himmel strahlt das problem christi das
schiff tor steht das ausrangierte
gefährt wird das herzstück des areals
bilden das im hektischen alltag freiraum
bieten will sich einen falte kreativ sie
gerne an und ich glaube dass ich da so
in der heutigen gesellschaft wo immer
schneller installiert wir die
gitarristen wird so wichtig und es wird
gelenke wichtiger dass man film erhalten
[Musik]
drei räume erkämpft hat dagegen eine
jugendbewegung die 1980 entbrennt
[Musik]
er hat nirgends ruhe der ganzen
aufregung überhaupt eröffnet staffel
zusammen am vortag war ruhig dasitzen
neues gerätehaus der macht nun aber
dampf rostock von vielen schweizern ist
hoch
diese kraft erfasst doch heutige
jugendliche sehr viel mehr gemeinsam hat
mit 80 als wir machen wird danke
der drang nach freiraum und seine folgen
[Musik]
ein alternatives kulturzentrum in der
roten fabrik und ein autonomes
jugendzentrum diese forderung nach dem
schalen 1980 durch ziel ich erstmals als
jugendliche zum protest vor dem
opernhaus aufrufen
das ist ein macher
[Musik]
ein 60 millionen kredit für das
opernhaus und weiterhin nichts für
jugendkultur dieser konflikt wird auf
einen schlag im ganzen land bekannt
knapp am wochenende in zürich
[Musik]
mit stadler die den beiden ach ich werd
berufstätige sind im bus charakter sagt
béla kubick 41 prozent ausgegangen und
hat sich mit bürgerschaft
[Musik]
selbstverwirklichung stadt angepasstheit
in einer gesellschaft die keinen platz
zur entfaltung bietet freiraum wird zum
politikum
[Musik]
markus keller ist 24 und arbeitet
zurzeit als motorrad kurieren er nimmt
seit beginn aktiv an der jugendbewegung
teilen schon vor den krawallen setzt er
sich für ein autonomes jugendhaus einer
momentan gar zum faire mode schnitte
staat abschaffen verkauft haben aber
dass mir wenigstens bereichen wo mir
selbst bestimmen was man macht und wie
man leben und das ist jugend tools der
mangel aufregen oder quasi das völlige
freiheit hat dazu geführt dass ich ein
paar hunderttausend user jungs genau das
ist das manko dass bruch des start-ups
bruch der ganzen schweiz erhöhung für
uns
um ihren der bevor man in der roten
fabrik und an das war besetzungen und
dem ausgemachten und petitionen mit
schriften sind vor stadt slaiten bitte
sehr
würde die reise bis k
[Musik]
schnitt passiert ja sich momentan der
einzige was mir oft strauss kahns für
die vorträge demonstrieren besonders
beliebt als gar nicht übrig es ist ein
generationenkonflikt sie die stadträte
und stadträtinnen so sind alle 60
rückblick sie also mindestens haben dass
es so woltmann sind normal wenn man
fehler verlor gast aus amerika überhaupt
die rockfabrik wnt der schmiere wichtig
sie das seinerzeit unter rote fabrik
gibt ist am stadtturm klage aber der
ganze untersuchung angeboten im herbst
auf druck von der straße hat die stadt
und das eine freiwillige elke hat zu mir
oder hatte mahler teilte und dann noch
alles möglich und dann all my und die
heute existiert seit 40 jahren wichtige
führung die rote fabrik projekt die
biografie des archivars einst
organisierte er dort konzerte mit der
gruppierung lockt als revolte
nun hilft er mit ihre geschichte in
einem buch aufzuarbeiten
dabei sticht ins auge wie mit den
jugendlichen auch die kunst aus
tradierten normen ausbricht
das ist genau die grafiken stand er in
der fabrik in seinem blog vor der roten
fabrik das sind bank grafik schnipsel
zum teil ein rückgriff auf wunsch die
der sowjetunion
dadurch ist die spielfläche sind
vielfach und spätere bewerbung über nova
sind modern gestaltete grafik blockaden
zweifelsohne entwickeln wo zum teil
heute noch sehenswert ich will es
einfach die derzeit sehr gut
dokumentiert
eisbär
dieses massive ästhetik drückt das
lebensgefühl einer generation aus die
sich gefangen fühlt im eisigen klima
einer konservativen gesellschaft
der 1
[Applaus]
[Musik]
einen klimawandel fordert auch diese
bewegung in der atmosphäre und in der
gesellschaft
dafür geht fiona diaboli 2009/10 auf die
straße die klima streik aktivistin
werden wir ein jahr lang begleiten
wie alle akteure des films
[Musik]
es ist eigentlich das einzige mittel
wird die einfälle sind
die junge wohnt nicht in abstimmen wie
kann ich mir zeit zu mir die politische
arbeit was machen
ja lucia
richtig
[Musik]
sondern dem orga
die protestierenden heute nennen sich
fridays for future die protestierenden
1980 zb freaks und friedlich sie alle
kritisieren die ressourcen ausbeuten und
gewinnmaximierung der konsumgesellschaft
doch erst die klima jugend wird nicht
mehr einfach als störenfried abgetan
[Musik]
es braucht eine politik
dies mache verschiedenen sprachen
arbeiten die manager hätten schnell
reagiert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im sommer 2009 10 erhält ein
stillgelegtes industriegeländes sein
fehlendes puzzlestück aus irland ins
basler hafengebiet gelotst von tom
brunner
das schiff liegt
sehr gut aus
[Musik]
der landgang führt in den holz park eine
bewilligte zwischennutzung für
gastronomie handwerk und kultur
doch es gibt lärmklagen nun braucht das
offene areal einen geschlossenen
veranstaltungsraum das schiff es vereint
für katja reichenstein funktionalität
und symbolkraft
[Musik]
die bewies dass meine träume umsätze um
das mehr als der gesang von dampf machen
soll ist wieder
wie möglich werner paar meter
und wie man die blumen
zusammen mit einem trägerverein
kuratiert das paar das alternative areal
zeit beginnt 2014
[Musik]
die erste installation smarte knie
[Applaus]
die stadt braucht alles damit jedes
quartier durch begann ich zu üben und
über kultur und kunst ist das möglich
und ich wünsche mir dass der organische
wachstum module sind stolz nicht auf
einer knolle fall will der star bereit
stehen wieder verschwindet einstweilen
steht der präsident des benachbarten
quartiervereins bereit
ein kritischer beobachter des holz parks
der junge war wir waren halt noch länger
feststeht ob das littering problem lösen
penicillin vertan das lecke oder die
rahn cascada massivem highlights von
unternehmen otto überlegt er sich näher
tritt überhaupt noch immer waren
schlafen und somit oder und
sachbeschädigung kann man auch auf der
heimat das ist das wolle keiner
vertragen und das finden wir schlachten
dom ist das warum ist die definition
fallen
die heutige jugend haben mit dem frühen
morgen im umgang
alle ins boot holen
diese offenheit passt zu einem raum der
nicht genommen sondern durch die stadt
gegeben wird
für ihre trading mehr abschotten
was positiv ist wird wo
entscheidungsträgern das mit trage ich
dass man eine befreiung viel offener
gestalten
und ich glaube das ist die pionierarbeit
für deine menschen mit völlig mittrage
und dabei offen gestalten und
[Musik]
weiterentwickeln soziale
weiter entwickeln von 1980 da muss
freiraum noch erkämpft und von den
behörden abgegrenzt werden
[Musik]
was für das jugend wo stehst du vor
ja ich stelle mir das an unseren großer
nehmen groß trierer theater um sie und
dass er gewinnt die zeit alles als
autonom
die präsentationen und ausstellungen
aber selbst da immer wieder von der
sport tag nach meiner autonome jugend
heißt es zum letzten mal mit
nachhaltigkeit europa wieder globus kann
erzählt was ich eine 12 jahre zürich hat
man abwarten ist ein foto geschossen ist
dann ist das vom
versicherungsgesellschaft
verwaltungsgebäude bis zum zubehör teile
ich das alles noch mal gras jugendhaus
öfter aber nicht als größtes autonomes
jugendzentrum
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in diese turbulente zeit tauchten
nicolai platz 1 der dramaturg und
zürcher theater neumarkt plant ein stück
zum thema protest mit klima aktivisten
und laien schauspielerin fiona tja
bohren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nicht nur die begrüßung erfolgt auf
distanz auch die aufführung rückt den
unbestimmte ferne wegen cholera gibt es
statt proben in der gruppe einzel
besprechung also die den stier das neue
mehr zum versammlungssaal wird und eben
irgendwie es klassisches theaterstück
wird so schöne sätze wäre rang und
wissen zu erlassen das ist essenziell
ist dass die produktion muss und protest
um mythos straßen und lud worden wo wir
etwas verändere dass man die geister
er wickelt etwa mit historischen
aufnahmen das ganze foto musste einen
protest vor
zentral sind und natürlich da 80
für die 20 jährige die gelegenheit 2020
mit einer zeit zu vergleichen die weit
vor ihrer geburt liegt 19 80 megawatt
identifiziert also zu dem hintergrund
dass man also demonstrierten dass der
jetzige csu operieren die gewähr dass
pilze szene gibt es halt wenn wir also
generell eigenes doch im klima stark
altbekannt ist mit der polizei
kooperieren und versuchte zweimal lösung
finden
doch mit form von protest ich sicher
anders aber der inhalt wird sage ich gar
nicht mal so verschieden also
schlussendlich als arm
gesellschaftswandel um sind die frage
vom status quo nicht wer uns federhalter
trotzdem mit wir jetzt die welt laufen
dass man aber versuchen das innen
geboren sind und gar nicht liegt das
saarland wird die welt funktioniert
jeder prozess hatte sie nie ritual
was ihn zu dritt waren momente in denen
du auf der straße so großen sicher dass
es spaß macht so dass man schon im 2
alias markus keller im stück berater zu
kopecky zwecks drin dass wir besser sind
beliebt genug also direkt war haben wir
es und macht sie für andere kabellose
hälftige wo ich nicht demonstrieren sie
zum teil vorher nicht
anspruch der polizei angetroffen
heftigen angst vor prügel ort
das sind 110 der kosten also die hand
nur dass auch entspannt können
ich studiere wenn wir das machen sich
situationsbedingt sie zur vorbereitung
erhält fiona kategorie songs von damals
hatte die cdu mit zucker bands im umfeld
von rote fabrik und potash und würde
vorschlag raums mit seiner box
bewegungspark banksy
[Musik]
ddp
musik die zu einem art passt der
elektrisiert und identität stiftet
gaslieferungen dann das wäre sehr
verstößen ort wünschen er könnte sich
und das machen was mit wannen trendy
also was wir ab toleriert wird wie er
mir schafft mit den anderen was für
ideal werden mehr hand klappt das ist
schon essentielle punkt ganz zum geld
wir lange als weil sie beweglich weiter
bestand so schaffen wir den orts finden
kann
mit dem lied zusammen bringen wo man
sich an uns schon zu wittern
diese sehnsucht erfüllt sich im ajz ab
juni 1980
allerdings nur vorübergehend in den
ständigen auseinandersetzungen stirbt
sie fast ab
[Musik]
das hilft wo am morgen nach der
krawallnacht einfach darsteller auf der
straße umbenannt
über die ereignisse und jetzt stellt das
mal vor aber normaler tag würde japan
ins stocken lassen was findet die heidi
junge probleme und ihr sie noch so
glauben sie das wirken der publizist und
mit rede
offenbar ist das generationen sprach in
gang kommt denn jetzt sprach in gang
kommt dann hält der krawalle negative
wir kriegen positiven sprach abbricht
dem glasklaren stimme
[Musik]
[Applaus]
doch
[Musik]
vor den augen einer ganzen nation kämpft
die jugend um ihre anliegen teils mit
dreister ironie ich darf mir vorstelle
somit weiter von der jugendbewegung
anna müller unter hans müller entlarven
live nachher gibt es im i satz und
winzigen ruhrgebiet war es versuchen das
römer mit einigen gummi partei die mit
einiger gummi partner endlich haben wir
nicht so gut da und die lichtquelle
trinken
[Musik]
was mit brauche die stadt trage nur
mitregieren umarmen der jugend beweglich
ist und dann statt revolution von hand
[Musik]
diskussion an ob er plötzlich während
ich danke den mann an der spitze
[Musik]
statt konfrontation kooperation die
freiraum betreiber und katja
reichenstein informieren das quartier
über ihr schiffs projekt mit den
behörden als partner
sie lassen den holz park
verantwortlichen freie hand solange er
die breite bevölkerung anspricht
freiraum wird zum instrument des
standortmarketings zu den freiraum
erobere richtig ist so dass man auch
viel fläche nicht so viel ich habe auch
die industrielle automation im nutzt
oder jetzt sogar oder hoffe ein zu
verfügung stellt wenn man möglichkeit
hätte denn nicht vor
warum setzt der kanton ich stelle
einfach alles nicht möglich
somit machen danke ein umdenken hat
stattgefunden
das gehört dazu aus gesellschaft also
ort wo man möglichkeiten bietet
unterschiedliche formen vor
kreativ und verlost
darum glaube ich schon dass wenn sich an
stoffen wie die verehrung für ganz
billig erhalte uns beispiele dass dann
plötzlich gewaltig merkt da muss man gar
nicht dass man angst korsett aussetzen
also es ist sehr viel möglich auch
inhalt für unsere unseren sie stehen
aus diesem system ausbrechen möchte eine
kleine gemeinschaft die auf demselben
areal lebt aber nicht teil des holz park
projekts ist
sie nennt sich wagenplatz und lädt
behördliche einmischung ab eine
autonomie die geduldet wird
[Applaus]
jens stieg am vormittag braucht das land
waren im netz immer genug schlaf oder
versuchst dich nachher punkte er ist
schreiner und sozialpädagoge und uns
gegenüber einfach wohl ihn im kollektiv
kann er sich verwirklichen was mich sehr
fasziniert ist dass man zur antwort ich
muss über das man selber kann
ausprobieren was haushalt vorhandene
leiden in dem gemeinschafts in dem
mannschafts- konzept ihnen und ich habe
auch merkel das ist mir mehr so viel
selbstbestimmung gibt und ja ich musste
mich fasziniert das dass man der kreativ
sie und dass das ist wie so viel vom
eigenen mann vom eigenen tor weg ist um
das wohnprojekt mit drin hat sie wohnen
in warten
an denen arbeiten sie in der eigenen
werkstatt ihre gemeinschaft im
einvernehmen mit dem holz park aber eine
besetzung welten prallen aufeinander wie
makro ausführt der
veranstaltungstechniker ist dass alle
hochhäuser ein star und ein klassischer
gentrifizierung manier damit dass jetzt
herrscht für hipster damit man nachher
der boden gut und tüchern verkaufen
das ist ganz anders wird aus mir machen
worum soll es ein bedürfnis nach der
wohnform und außenpolitische haltung so
entsteht wo wir es lieber wenn andere
schlafen sich ökonomischen zwängen
entziehen dem diktat der konsum und
leistungsgesellschaft das streben sie an
[Musik]
für mich freiraum heißt eigentlich dass
es frei für profis und ich finde wenn
man eine ruhm hat von dem profit danke
loslösen
dann ist schon mal so viel freiheit gut
sie wünschten sich mehr leben und leben
lassen
doch gewisse regulierungen bleiben
premium heißt nicht öffentlich für allen
jedem kontext oder wenn ich liebe das
ist das ist schon das ganze kompliziert
macht oder sobald der freihof europa
genutzt wird herta who freizeit mit
einer hypothek
und dann muss man von großhändler mit
land und wir dass wir das mit seinem
coach irrt sie wissen ihr freiraum ist
ebenfalls begrenzt er besteht nur so
lange wie es denn holz park gibt
ganz autonom agiert auch die rote fabrik
nicht
seit beginn 1980 erhält sie städtische
subventionen
[Musik]
das stört markus keller nicht wenn die
kulturelle vielfalt profitiert die
republik aus fairer und ist
ausgangspunkt für viele kulturschaffende
bot eine erstemission projekt hotel es
kommt mir bisher taten bereich der
metalle für trillerpfeifen und viele
andere theater kapazität entstanden
vieles was guckt etabliert ich hatte von
anfang an kontur
[Musik]
40 jahre später geht es dem archivar
darum diese geschichten weiterzutragen
recherche treffen mit philipp an dem
hauptautor der chronik zur roten fabrik
diego ich hab dich da die ganze ziemlich
punk und new wave szene taxi total 1
konzertkarten dir bezwingt kleenex
liliput steht vorreiter hat da
angefangen wird sich erste sommerkonzert
machen not ist groß zimmern ort braucht
neue regeln des staates oder ganz so wie
die ganze schweiz ist ein beruf
[Musik]
fabrik stadt haben sich eigentlich gar
nicht vorstellen dass es momentan nicht
ge hat in stadt zürich dass es
unglaublich wie sich die stadt verändert
hat dank der roten fabrik wo ich meine
hoffnung ist kulturell politisch
inhaltlich
[Musik]
die kurz immer wichtig sie bis heute und
ich finde es wichtig dass es die gibt ob
es jetzt voll auto dort sind oder ob du
eigentlich situation beziehen
aber der größte frei muss es sie und
quasi kommerz frei im archiv stoßen sie
auf einen konflikt von 1980 ein mieter
stand mit seinen lagerräumen dem
kulturzentrum im weg das opernhaus und
darf nur eine technik mit nein nur
grauer da diskutieren da das ist kein
thema dass ich beim paradeplatz
opernhaus raus aus der roten verglichen
[Musik]
noch dieses jahr soll er fertig werden
der kulturraum im basler schiff
kostenpunkt rund eine million
für die bank für die tom brunner eine
hypothek aufgenommen
andere oder öffentlich herum damit
gestalten
mit dem projekt mit dem spiel die hand
gibt ja schon sagt risiko wird genau
erklären können wieso ich nicht prima
früh sich sonst allgemeinheit
aber es wird sich lohnen gesellschaft
die kann auch schiff- und areal kreative
ideen umsetzen damit will katja
reichenstein einen begegnungsort
schaffen sich nicht mehr abgrenzen wie
einst als besetzerinnen zürich
gerade zum beispiel sehr mühe die
führung mit gewalt muss verteidigt das
bin ich gerade das von eltern vorgelebt
dass mich oft mit mit der seele kommt
ein anderer ausgang sich mit radikal
geld verdient sie als kultur vermitteln
der holzbau ist leidenschaft
wie für ihn den technischen leiter eines
tonstudios
[Musik]
das mehr antritt ist genau das was ich
versuchen erfahrung schaffen der
umgebung wohnen befinden oder mehr
aufsuchen
mit der stadt basel witz machen
beziehungslos was ist möglich
vieles ihr träger verein bewilligte etwa
ein brockenhaus einen
gemeinschaftsgarten einen ägyptischen
imbiss alles land nutzungen zu tiefen
tarifen zur erhaltung des gesamtprojekts
[Musik]
es ist der absolute kontrast war
ich habe mich sofort in dieses areal
verliebt und zu hause gefühlt
ja
mit gleichgesinnten kreiert fiona
diaboli eine webserie zum klima strang
verblüffend die parallelen zu filmen von
1980 wenn sie über ihre bewegung spricht
es macht extrem viel sehen die bewegung
dokumentieren will sas sata hilft zwar
beruflich tür zum keller verstaubt dann
passieren nicht momentan bewegt und
anders sieht es natürlich auch für busse
stehen die letzte lied von nicht so viel
mit beweg eine möglichkeit zum wechsel
orgie mit was führt ebene mir also was
länder gestaltet und ein schönes reiter
unberechtigt hat das unterstellen aber
meistens stück der bevor ich ihn nach
außen tragen könnte das altern erdrückt
von den werbekampagnen ertränkt im
permanenten kampf um auflösen könnten
wie also höre ich meinen eigenen welt
schmerzfrei zu zürich city großraumbüro
rentabel
doch zum wohnen leider ungeeignet
zürich city parkhaus für pendler und
motorisierte alles käufer abgase
zerfressen sandsteinfassaden in den
letzten wohnlichen quartieren lärm und
stress geben ihnen den rest
für die brenz inspirierte viele etwa
christoph schaub
der regisseur in szene dem
nachfolgeprojekt des kino betriebs im
ajz austausch mit markus keller über ein
werk aus der bewegung für die bewegung
und bestzeit
[Musik]
also für mich ist es ist das große
explosion
sie ist befreiung sind diese musik
gegangen ist grafik film dass man das so
zu sagen wir können sich artikulieren
und ist auch ein provokatives sachen
machen und ich habe zwar gehört also
anders film gemacht wird also zur
geplanten und die andere bewegungen
haben für mich gewirkt als das was ich
im kino zu sehen
das ist wirklich einfach nicht okay dass
man dass wir vielen neu entdeckt das
halt ich dass man das inflations videos
im film mühen zu zeigen schnell
funktionieren
es bewege
[Musik]
beispielhaft die dokumentation schwimmen
die protestaktion filmt schneidet und
präsentiert christoph schaub noch am
gleichen tag dank mobiler kamera und
günstige videotechnologie sie
ermöglichen kreative freiräume
passend zum lebensgefühl
[Applaus]
[Musik]
oder sind immer materiell geografisch
sozusagen und gleichzeitig innerlich und
wann es innerlich nicht hat oder einen
kaffee spieler da haben israel verübt
und umgekehrt
und von daher ist es sollen dialektik
zwischen beiden um beweglichkeit sehr
viel früher und auch innerlich immer
anschaulich gemacht haben und mehrkampf
für die bessere früh darum ist es so
wichtig in der einzelnen biografien von
der familie vereinbaren
den kampf um äußere freiräume zeigt
christoph schaub auch als er sich mit
der zürcher besetzer szene befasst sein
letzter film aus bewegten zeiten
[Musik]
2009 10 sind partys im öffentlichen raum
längst akzeptiert solange sie die regeln
beachten
wieder grossanlass bietende street der
sich alle zwei jahre auf dem holz park
einmietet
als spiegelbild unserer gesellschaft die
die stadt das areal und vips uralt
mittlerweile bereich und mit amazon oben
machen dass man da sein
im rahmen so dass bei der
im legalen bereich passiert aber es ist
sehr schwierig ja
[Musik]
die gesellschaft ist seit 1980
toleranter geworden und hedonistische
viele wollen neues entdecken suchen
freiräume doch die sind rares gut
start wird halt immer dichter und so
viel wie du läufst du gefahr ausgeht
platzmäßig 1000 oder mehr möglich wir
die nächste generation den platz und
fremdartigen utzigen den abschluss
gestaltet traditionell der gastgeber
selbst freilich nur bis mitternacht um
das quartier zu schonen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
in zeiten von corona beliefert fiori
hilfsbedürftige mit nahrungsmitteln
so kann sie sich weiterhin sozial
engagieren während die fortsetzung von
theaterstück und klimabewegung ungewiss
ist
mich persönlich sind extrem
also es ist so dass wir jetzt das
projekt kann und ich wie du darfst du
sofort da kannten sogar das ganze spiele
klimastreit das merkt dass wir sehr
schwierig ist nur über carlsen social
media und so irgendwie sache
organisieren und die weststadt
[Musik]
erinnerungen werden wach
etwa ans klima festival 2009 10 in
zürich das derzeitige verbot solcher
aktionen schränkt die bewegung stark ein
und verkompliziert ihre gesamt situation
zusätzlich
[Musik]
sind momentan an dem punkt dass ich
wirklich schwierig wird wissen wir
wieder also als auch mit fragen was
folgen für ihre langfristige strategie
will jetzt nachdem im jahr was so mega
der aufschwung der hat ja wieviel jahr
wird das jetzt nur weiterbestehen wir
wir machen wir wieder sehr viel von
stationen der schlussendliche gewähr
ja noch mehr halt immer noch ziemlich am
gleichen punkt sind und eigentlich schon
noch nicht so viel faktisch erreicht
handelns aufmerksam keit
[Musik]
am morgen nach dem beat und es trieb die
spaßgesellschaft forderte ihren tribut
das wäre eigentlich wird das areale so
dass es halt einfach wirklich zum teil
wirklich lieblos genutzt wird beinhalten
musik dass menschen zusammenführe das
wiederum führe wo sie doch das
verstanden die und das macht für mich
extrem so sinnig merkel ich möchte nicht
dass die veranstaltungen der stadt wien
es ist eine güterabwägung grossanlässe
bringen einnahmen
doch das hat seinen preis
ich denke man einfach zu wenigstens
pflanzenwelt
[Musik]
während rocker nicht nur freund und los
sondern eigentlich wo wir sind wir
nutzen und das ist das was eine zweifach
macht aber verantwortlich leiten wird
[Musik]
freiraum ist immer umständen biete
geschichte des zürcher az verdeutlicht
[Musik]
die behörden dulden keine autonomie die
bewegten keine einmischung das
gegenseitige unverständnis ist gewaltig
[Applaus]
ein teil der demonstranten abgeriegelt
jugendzentrum und salz besetzter begriff
[Musik]
was kann man tun
rauchen verboten ist von ihr noch ich
weiß dass die kammer von raw-daten
resultat wieder einmal schwere
auseinandersetzung verletzungen und
verhaftungen am sonntag wieder probiert
mit dafür zu erwärmen wir sind ja nur
aus bösewichte sondern wir sind alle
wünschen und planen und träumen und zu
reden das web lagern bewirkt vertraut
[Musik]
sie streben nach einem gegenentwurf zur
saturierten konsumgesellschaft
was ist denn da ordentlich wir haben
xl versorgen
[Musik]
ihr persönlicher freiraum ist das
atelier im elterlichen zuhause hier
kommt lola deponie zur ruhe und bleibt
trotzdem engagiert
endlich spricht dass ich werde ihre
kunst und ich mache message haltige user
bringt will ich bin für mich nur so dass
die frauen sind hat so stark höchste
stetig bin und das ja das schon die
frage stellen sagte sie wir haben
verbinden den besuch damit so eine
optimale dämmung gemacht haben manchem
und ex etwa und demonstrierte sind die
besucher mitbringen ist ein flyer nicht
ist ein dann für dem am 28 märz zeigt
sie wonach abgesagt worden nicht mehr
ohne dass du da ist fleißig sie für das
festival der rockfabrik stattfindet oder
abgesagt wird nicht
[Musik]
ihr projekt dagegen geht weiter die
behörden haben es verlängert um fünf
jahre mit aussicht auf 10 zeit die
mitstreiter im trägerverein mehr
einzubeziehen sehr verpflichtet alles
einzelne von art meets betreuen und
begleiten sondern für mich wieso bitte
leg los los vom ganze frei herum da und
man gute gefühl will erben aber
natürlich sie also zurücklehnen und aber
befreien können
also nicht so wie die letzte aktion wo
man hat immer der front alles sauber
machte es kommt jetzt glaubt das projekt
andere generation nachhaltiger und mit
mir
[Musik]
von einer zeit von der fabrik vom sommer
80 100 die vorbilder und zum teil
tauchte träumen immer noch positiven wie
im negativen
ja ja das gesetzt
si
ein zufluchtsort gleich hinter dem
zürcher hauptbahnhof bis märz 1982
[Musik]
grund gegangen oder viele probleme lösen
schnitt für das vorbereitete stadt hat
ihr problem quasi delegierten lang ist
[Musik]
es ist fast too much gesehen sehr
schwierig sondern ort will autonom heißt
der rundum zu hofe und ausgesetzter
gemacht hat ist quasi legal und dieter
problem aber ich habe sehr spannend oder
die herausforderung sei zu retten oder
schaffen das auto älter noch
funktionieren wo inklusive torhüter
morgen kurz vor der bühne bearbeitet
drucks hat schon gute teil von circa eur
zerbrochen
im handstreich vom zürcher stadtrat bis
kurz vor der aktion kein kauf
[Musik]
immerhin der abbruch wird ein aufbruch
zu mehr offenheit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die sehnsucht nach freiraum beschäftigt
noch heute nach faßberg sie was es heißt
dass sie jung bewegt
[Applaus]
sie bewegen sich sehr viel mehr
gemeinsam hat mit der jugendbewegung
also man machen danke
[Musik]
wieder ungleich schätzen
muss es sein beruf bauer muss es lieber
weiter vorne gestellt werden sondern man
muss selber aufbaut passieren ganz viel
erfolgen
darum wünsche ich dass die jetzige
generation von der klima auch über das
zentrum oder mehrere dezentrale ort
geführt wo sie die erfolge um ihre hand
teufel machen brauche machen
[Musik]
da